aux origines du funk la sueur positive
n'est les concerts à la nouvelle orléans
la salle d'exposition du brillant coup
propose jusqu'au 17 mars une
rétrospective de l'histoire de la
musique funk de sa naissance jusqu'à ces
mutations
l'exposition qui couvre le quinzaine
d'années revient sur les figures
emblématiques et le grands courants
musicaux à travers un parcours
chronologique c'est incontournable
lorsqu'on fait une exposition qui par
les origines on va on va s'intéresser à
l'histoire et le contexte historique
dans lequel n'est un mouvement musical
donc là effectivement le sphinx et la
voix de james brown s'exprime à travers
une femme peintre qui expriment les
bleus à l'âme de tout le noir américain
à l'époque qui était en pleine révolte
contre la ségrégation et très peu
connaître de cette époque là donc
effectivement le contexte historique
joue est un facteur qui est
incontournable des documents tels qu'une
fausse chronologique
les visiteurs peuvent évoluer parmi cinq
espaces thématiques où figurent entre
autres affiches pochettes de disques
d'or musique m le biographe
l'exposition qui se veut pédagogique et
ludique propose même un peu plus jeunes
livrés jeux à télécharger pour ne rien
oublier